Скрипка — це як музичний комп'ютер.
Тільки ним потрібно так, як комп'ютером...
Добрі комп'ютерники повинні володіти ним відповідно.
Аналогічно й зі скрипкою.
Якщо музикант добре володіє [скрипкою],
отже, він оволодів тим середньовічним «комп'ютером».
Я працюю 35 років.
Але спочатку я намагався щось пізнати з літератури.
Потім зрозумів, що я зайшов у глухий кут.
Необхідно йти вчитися.
Вступив до Італії, до Міжнародного інституту імені Страдіварі.
Там здобував високопрофесійну, фахову освіту.
Фактично в Україні лише я і моя дружина [маємо таку освіту].
Я — професійний музикант,
вчився в консерваторії у Львові по класу альта.
Моя дружина — віолончелістка,
тобто ми — сім'я музикантів.
Я керував 23 роки камерним оркестром.
Ми об'їхали майже всю Європу з тим оркестром:
у Лондоні були чотири рази з гастролями, в Італії, Австрії.
Одно слово, багато де [побували].
Розумієте, грати на скрипці — це своя галузь,
а створювати скрипку — це стиль життя.
Тому що музикант, який вже оволодів повністю інструментом,
постійно концертує і грає.
І він вивчив фактично повний перелік
усіх скрипкових творів.
А тут — постійно створюєш нове, нове, щось нове і нове.
Кожний інструмент фактично є своєрідним винаходом.
Мій маестро, Джіо Батто Морасі, казав мені,
що скрипкобудуванню треба вчитися все життя.
Це вже фактично остаточне завершення голови.
Тут вже все практично зроблено,
тільки потім ще сюди треба зробити гриф,
поставити з поріжком
і вже тоді можна його вклеювати ось сюди.
І все.
І тоді вже тут прорізається отаке заглиблення,
відповідно, сюди гриф вставляється.
Найважливіше в акустичному плані —
це посадити висоту грифа.
Оця чорна штука називається «гриф» — tastiera.
Його треба посадити на відповідній висоті від поверхні деки.
Якщо посадити його низько —
втрачається 35-40% звуку.
Ми спеціально їздили до Ліона у Франції,
був такий дуже знаменитий майстер Жак Фустьє.
Ми їздили до нього на майстер-класи
спеціально для того,
щоб навчитися як ставити висоту грифа.
Чесно скажу вам, без особливого пафосу:
кожна людина має перед собою якусь мету.
І коли ту мету перед собою ставиш...
Наприклад, ми як педагоги, бачили,
як наші учні, наші студенти мучилися і страждали
на тих інструментах, на яких вони грали.
Тому що переважно грали
на фабричних інструментах — старих, побитих...
І нашим завданням було
полегшити життя нашим українським дітям,
нашим українським музикантам,
щоб вони грали на порядних інструментах.
Тому що одного разу я чув інтерв'ю дуже
поважного і знаменитого професора-скрипаля,
який казав: «Нам не вдалося
перемогти на конкурсі. Чому?
Тому що інші учасники — з Канади,
зі США — грають на скрипках Страдіварі.
А наші діти не мають змоги грати
на таких дорогих і гарних інструментах.
Тому вони не перемагають на тих конкурсах».
І наше завдання було таке:
щоб наші діти перемагали на наших інструментах.
Був конкурс на Мальті,
і хлопчик на нашому інструменті переміг у конкурсі.
Взяв ґран-прі.
І після того все журі прийшло дивитися,
що це за інструмент.
Це є для нас великим задоволенням в тому,
що ми змогли своєю творчістю допомогти музиканту
творити шедеври і виконувати так, як він здатний.
Робота дуже цікава.
Фактично це навіть не можна
назвати роботою — це стиль життя.
Дуже цікаво,
і приносить задоволення, натхнення до життя.
Ми пенсіонери вже, але працюємо.
І мріємо ще створити свою «королеву».
[грає світлу мажорну мелодію]
А це наша модель.
Був один період, коли ми думали,
що не будемо повертатися в Україну.
Я виїхав 1999 року.
1985-1999 роки — це були надзвичайно
важкі часи для всіх наших людей в Україні.
Були [навіть] такі періоди, коли ми думали,
що не доживемо від зарплати до зарплати.
Коли ми приїжджали періодично, два рази на рік, в Україну,
коли були канікули в інституті,
ми бачили, що Україна розвивається.
Ми зрозуміли, що теж можемо внести свою частинку
таланту і творчості для розквіту України.
Ми тому й повернулися.
Я пригадав вислів Бернарда Шоу.
Його запитали: «Чим скрипка подібна до слона?».
Він відповів, що загалом нічим не подібна.
[Отже], тільки одна різниця:
скрипка зовсім не подібна до слона.
Аналогічно й тут: яка б чужа країна для тебе не була «рідна»,
своя [країна] все ж таки найрідніша.